and the whole family is going to find
these the best there's going to find
these I love this and why Donald Trump
the best what was that word well was
that sentence hey guys i'm abby char
welcome to Abby's kitchen summer is
finally here and you are not gonna want
to miss all of the delicious summer
recipes that we have going on here at
Abby's kitchen so definitely subscribe
to the channel and check out my favorite
playlist with all of the best summer
recipes right here now today I want to
do a little something sweet to accompany
all of our barbecue and our beer and our
cocktails all the good stuff in life
these are my watermelon fries with a
creamy coconut dip this is actually the
number one recipe on the Abby's kitchen
blog and I think a really good reason
because it is so delicious and so simple
just takes a handful of ingredients and
it's vegan gluten free dairy free so so
good but it's also an awesome dessert
and a really good snack that the whole
family will love so let's do this I
first start by slicing up a watermelon
into thin fry like strips
[Music]
then to make my coconut lime dip I take
some coconut yogurt add a generous
amount of lime zest some fresh lime
juice
and some coconut sugar to taste
[Music]
give that a good stir and set it aside
finally I season my watermelon with a
generous pinch of tagine classic
seasoning which is a combination of
chili lime and salt give it a good dip
and enjoy so guys I hope you enjoyed
this recipe for my watermelon fries the
creamy coconut lime dip if you did be
sure to give it a thumbs up leave me a
comment below with some of your favorite
summer recipes subscribe to the channel
and I'll see you next time on Abby's
kitchen bye
[Music]